on est en 1911 auour d'Amsterdam le
génial Franck Marshall multiple champion
des États-Unis cette position écrasante
avec les pièces noires donand il décide
tranquille de s'allumer un petit cigare
comme il en a l'habitude pour savourer
sa victoire s dans un geste malheureux
il renverse sa tour de l'échiquier là il
y a un fan absolu qui se précipite pour
lui ramasser et lui tendre la tour mais
martiall grand seigneur lui répond
aucune importance j'en ai pas besoin et
il va effectivement terminer la partie
sans sa tour et grâce à l'aide de ses
trois pions passaliers monstrueux
l'emporter a sans doute assisté au
sacrifice le plus cocasse de l'histoire
des échecs